trying to work out he did he did he
indeed played E4 A6 D4 then E6 and we
have D5 so a French with A6
fun times fun times and Simon you're the
French defense expert but A6 not the
most useful move in this position I know
that it's not the most principle but
there's some tricks here and uh although
I will say this Jordan played by C3
we're sitting here blabbering away it's
now Magnus who's on the clock until he
just plays Bishop B4
wow we were expecting yard and run for
us to make it funky in the opening but
it looks like Magnus is the one who's
bringing in the funk while this one
heats up it's sure to be a roller
coaster ride yeah we haven't been
playing too long but already Queens are
off all the Bishops are gone now it is
an end game and white has more space if
you look at the Pawns in the center of
the board and on the king side white has
advanced quite far there but due to the
lack of pieces actually white has a lot
of responsibility now white has a lot of
squares to cover and black is rock solid
uh especially with knights Anything Can
Happen they're gonna jump in and around
I'm seeing the Black Knight jumping into
White's Queen side very shortly I think
objectively it's roughly in the balance
but we all know magnus's reputation in
the end game can Jordan hold his own
there that's uh the big question he says
equal okay I'm the better player so an
equal position gives me more chances to
win and that is a weakness and this is
something which is uh very prevalent in
this type of structure but of course it
should be even at the moment and it's
easier to play with more space and I
think white should just push his King
side pawns try to create some weakness
over there but moving the king into the
middle seems very sensible as well and
then white maybe tries to use some sort
of grip Pawn structure on the king side
advancing for this G5 break the G5 brick
is often the the most dynamic one
because if G5 occurs black only has bad
choices if you take it you always give
the outside passer and if you leave it
white capturing H6 creates a weakness so
there's of course there's these crazy
ideas where you sacrifice everything for
a queen but that won't be the case here
so anyway I think that while we're
applauding Magnus I don't think Jordan
is in any danger in this game yeah I
just like Danny would choose white I
think there's less risk for white it
feels like if you just protect
everything you have a draw at hand but
so yeah if you want to play for a win I
was about to say Jordan paused at that
moment it looks a bit strange he's
changed the pawn structure he wants to
maybe break with this Pawn now he has
full defense over his Center maybe he's
just going to retreat his Knight say
everything's defended and uh go for
Glory on the king side white is
controlling all the cards right you'll
play G4 at some point you will decide
whether F5 or G5 is worth it maybe
that's part of magnus's psychological
plan is he believes in himself enough to
say come get me big fella and see if you
give me some chances once we're both
under time pressure but by the way
speaking of time pressure I think that's
the one thing we haven't called out it's
regardless of the X's and O's Magnus is
is doubly up on the clock and if you if
you just take another four minutes away
for both players and not much has
changed that'll be the thing Magnus is
playing for
and Jordan bond for us right now in full
control he's the one with all the pawn
breaks in the position the one with the
active Rook eyeing the beep on weakness
that black has potential breaks even
though I expect it to be a draw we did
see this G5 structure which is kind of
White's main plan H6 is going to fall
here even though Magnus is currently up
a pawn and if time pressure ensues
Knights are some of the trickiest pieces
we got the bullet Chess Championship
coming up this is about to be a bullet
battle with a little bit of increment
yeah and we all know how badly Knights
suffer against Rook spawns in this case
Harry the H porn for uh Simon here could
play a decisive role if Magnus isn't
able to deal with that and okay material
balance will be restored who would you
pick here evaluation boss says draw but
which side
do you think it's easier to play I mean
I'd definitely pick white here because
uh when you when you get to night
endings the most precious past Pawn to
have is the wing pawn and you can see
that Harry over there it could be strong
luckily why I don't know about luck but
Magnus has his King in front of that
pawn but a problem that you have when
you're defending against a Rooks Pawn is
that your knight can only defend it from
one side it can't jump off the board and
defend it from Another Side so uh I
definitely pick white here but unless
white can get his King in there's not
much material on the board you're
playing a pretty good end game player I
mean he's not bad is he if you're
playing me you'd have some chances
you're playing Danny even more chances
you're playing David no chances and um
yeah I mean sorry yeah we've got it
we've got to get it big on me all you
want I think we're about to see a
repetition it was yeah glad we came here
because it's the final instructor oh you
don't think so no I think Magnus
win that high
on and actually maybe even push on for a
couple of moves David are there any
chances of that happening certainly now
and uh Jordan he shook his head yeah he
lost this move he could have gone the
other way with this King he could have
cut out this option and I think like you
said Danny we would have seen a draw
within moments but suddenly big question
does white push the pawn allowing the
black king uh to either step forward or
to the side and that pawn will be weak
forever picked off soon or do you move
your knight forward where the black king
again is allowed forward suddenly big
question to answer yeah I apologize I I
was maybe just thinking about Simon
picking on me I guess but no I I it's
obvious that the white team needed to go
to F3 Danny you will get your revenge
we've got plenty of days left my friends
left but no the H1 is going to fall
you're right Tanya this is Jordan's not
got plenty of time left he's got 25
seconds on the clock the line is on the
board David the one that you were
calling out now there are two pieces
attacking the h-bond I don't see a way
for white to keep it together yeah that
pawn is dropping and well Jordan pushes
his King to D4 what is the expected
reply after Knight takes Pawn suddenly
there's a threat of nitrade the F4 Pawn
as well for white is hanging yeah I
think the one the one lucky thing Jordan
has going for him is just the F7 F7 is
tender the moment the black king gets
too aggressive right you play Knight G4
check and on King G6 King E3 and you say
all right I screwed up now show me right
and like and it will black be able to
make progress without Knight H6 coming
in asking Magnus to show how to win a
pawn up that is scary it's really scary
I mean for sure you can ask Magnus a lot
of questions but I've seen him win so
many unwinnable endings uh just sitting
on the you know sitting here he does it
so often especially when uh the the
clock is very low but I mean how how
realistic do you think that is David I
mean here that Magnus couldn't can win
this well that's the thing if it was
anyone else in the world I'd say
Jordan's gonna draw
um we also see the evaluation bar so
objectively it should still be a draw
yeah Magnus still needs a bit of magic
but yeah we've seen him milk these types
one of the things I was asking these is
if I could pass the move would that be
progress and I think one of the problems
is even if black could pass the move the
white king will now sit on E3 and F3 and
if the D4 Pawn ever pushes you'll go to
E4 so I don't
and you can't you can't exchange pawns
so I'm sort of I'm sort of wondering if
uh if there's any real way to trick
white here but if there is Magnus
Carlson we'll find it full disclosure
but I I still think that Jordan is gonna
hold a draw despite blundering to get
here I think Jordan will hold although
right as I say it I'm now looking at the
d-pawn and starting to look at some real
crazy lines so Simon now Magnus will
crush it no no doubt about it I mean
Magnus is just gonna grind it grind it
find an opportunity the problem is
Jordan has to play so accurately I mean
even though as you pointed out Danny
it's not easy to win at all uh Magnus
can keep trying stuff and as soon as I
say that they're repeating Kings but um
yeah I mean it's not easy to win but
David what do you reckon you've got to
have the you're gonna have the deciding
yeah the deciding what I don't know
Tanya you need to vote too but I'll say
draw because it feels like Jordan has
set up really nicely with his pieces but
he's going for the win he refused the
third time repetition here so Magnus
going to try till the end yeah Magnus
he'll play till King versus King if he
needs to we've seen that before from him
but whether he's successful to win
that's another question it feels like
Jordan's got his Knight on a perfect
circuit right now why tonight is
stopping the advance of Black's extra
Pawn the Deep one and it can give the
black king some annoying checks too F5
is always going to be a way to try and
trade pawns uh for white later if you
can arrange it
well I'm talking myself into a corner
here but I'll say draw the good news is
we don't have a lot of other games to
get to we already had two quick draws
between oronian and ferozev and so and
Notre back abdusa toroff respectively so
we've got this game in the Fabiano game
so I'm willing to just stay right here
until we we see Magnus show us whether
he's going to find a way or not
in 12 seconds for Jordan van Forest he
does repeat with the knight in King and
that's all that he has to do right
Shuffle it around with the Knight and
the King makes sure that Black's King
doesn't get active then is there a
potential winning plan in this position
for black here
I think you have to be able to advance
Steve if we want to bring up the
analysis more we might as well show how
it works right so if if black can
advance the d-pawn not really because
you have hopes of queening but because
you can distract the white king in the
right opportunity for the black king to
go to G6 and F5 the problem is you have
to do it where the Knight is also
somehow sidelined himself because
otherwise F7 is a problem or as we see
now check right so the right way to do
this is to advance the d-pawn that first
distracts the Knight to B4 David and
then it then distracts the king only at
that time if the Knight is sidelined on
the queen side and the King has
retreated could black win so we'll see
might be three great colder Danny it's
on the board he wants to get the Deep on
moving but but the thing is you have to
okay and now now Jordan sees a chance
actually I think this is a great move I
think Jordan has just clinched that
because you get one more Pawn off the
board and suddenly you're in sack
territory right sack the night for the
remaining pawns and you should be able
to draw
good strategy isn't it David I mean when
when you're uh trying to draw exchange
off as many pawns as you can because
there's less to worry about really you
know there's just one trap in the
position just to show you it didn't fall
for it if you've taken this point I love
it
heart attack don't make Tanya fall off
the chair there you go if you take the
pawn bad things happen yeah if the
knights disappear black will win due to
this protective passport but this didn't
happen in the game and uh Jordan's still
holding the balance this is the game
position he will trade off at least one
set of Pawns and should make a draw
we're getting another update that
idrisaga Fabiano also ended in a draw so
that's three draws will this be the
fourth drawer right now Jordan seems to
be there not anymore he blundered his
Knight he walked his Knight into a trap
because the Nikon's before the night
guards do you know what he just never
bet against Magnus College 96 can be
seven and then oh can be seven the
knights out of squares
you probably would have just repeat it
and now any where you lose the night but
White's coming out of the pawns it's not
going to be enough David but what is
happening can you just take that white
and I just take it and then Knight F4
king of fire and then just keep pushing
oh it's so tricky now though white snack
has escaped but the pawn is rolling
maybe Magnus has played it perfectly now
the white King has to give way and oh my
God
and this is how it's done yeah I mean Mr
Carlson strikes again normal normal you
know normal Magnus Carlson you know just
when it looks like it's going to be a
draw uh he he just finds the way to put
problems on his opponent